[Musique]
c'est
bonsoir à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes à montigny le bretonneux au
siège dé mitec ce groupe est composé de
cette filiale et réalise 50 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires c'est une
société spécialisée dans la
certification et les tests des nouveaux
produits mis sur le marché
elle est engagée notamment dans le
secteur automobile est face à la crise
sanitaire
elle se tourne vers le véhicule hybride
électrique et à hydrogène c'est ce que
vous allez découvrir dans ce douzième
numéro du sky échos face à la
multiplication des attaques
informatiques l'entreprise guillon pour
toi koxie box propose sa solution
gratuitement collectivités et aux
structures publiques et mitec est
spécialisée dans les essais sur les
nouveaux produits mis sur le marché pour
se relancer l développe cette activité
sur les moteurs de véhicules électriques
hybrides ou à hydrogène
enfin rencontre avec randy luc usa ce
jeune dirigeant saint quentinois vient
de lancer son entreprise
après avoir suivi une formation de
développeurs web le centre hospitalier
de dax et celui de villefranche sur
saône ont subi courant février des
cyberattaques
face à l'augmentation de cette menace la
start-up auxi box implantée à guyancourt
propose ses services gratuitement aux
administrations publiques
victime d'une cyber-attaque la mairie de
fouilles s'est rapproché de cette
société pour en bénéficier
regardez c'était le 29 janvier dernier
les services municipaux 2 où il victime
d'une attaque informatique directeur des
systèmes d'information externalisés pour
la commune thomas herbert a accompagné
la municipalité face à soeren somewhere
une cyber attaque avec demande de rançon
le crypto d'auteur et a pu pénétrer le
système d'information et le réseau à
travers une faille du firewall dus
principalement en fait à l'obsolescence
des matériaux et
une mauvaise mise à jour en fait des
différentes versions ça bloque
complètement toutes les applications
métiers david les finances les
ressources humaines mais également tout
ce que j'ai une vive donc le la gestion
d'état civil le cimetière l'aide sociale
la police municipale etc pour remettre
en place le système thomas herbert a
pris contact avec l'entreprise auxi box
situé à guyancourt
il y a quelques semaines cette société
spécialisée dans la cybersécurité a
lancé une offre gratuite destinée aux
administrations publiques une solution
de redémarrage de l'activité après une
attaque
l'idée c'est de leur permettre de
s'équiper maintenant rapidement devoir
prendre une décision facile afin de
parer à l'urgence puisque il ya une
épidémie aujourd'hui qui se propage une
épidémie de rands somewhere qui se
propage aussi bien dans les hôpitaux
sujet est pris à bras le corps par les
pouvoirs publics que dans les
collectivités territoriales
cette société guyancourt toise a déjà
reçu plus d'une centaine de demandes de
la part d' administration publique
[Musique]
45 % de son activité réalisée dans le
secteur automobile le groupe elitech
emploie plus de 500 salariés
son activité validé et certifié le bon
fonctionnement des produits testés
aujourd'hui l'entreprise bénéficie du
plan en france relance notamment pour le
développement du véhicule du futur et
pour en parler nous sommes avec
sébastien poteau bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
et
vous êtes le directeur des opérations
autour de la mobilité au sein du groupe
elitech comment avez vous vécu cette
année 2020 et l'impact de la crise
sanitaire
alors chez les mitec est
particulièrement un secteur de la
mobilité on a vécu deux crises ou deux
changements majeurs on va dire une crise
la crise du comice bien sûr et puis une
crise sectorielle une mutation
sectorielle puisque quand vous avez pu
le voir on voit de plus en plus de
véhicules électrifiés emitech père était
partie prenante des tests autour des
véhicules électrifiés que ce soit sur
les batteries goût sur les moteurs
électriques ont testé aussi beaucoup de
moteurs à combustion sur les sites
d'achères et nouveaux ronds mois il a
fallu accélérer notre développement de
moyens d'essais de compétences sur toute
l'année 2019 et surtout 2020 pour
pouvoir prendre le virage des
validations de ces deux composants
majeurs à savoir la batterie les moteurs
électriques et son électronique de
puissance
finalement c'est une crise qui a eu un
impact je peux sur votre activité avec
une chute peut être de votre chiffre
d'affaires mais en même temps il ya une
opportunité derrière exactement dans
toute crise il ya une opportunité alors
la cheffe de la baisse du chiffre
d'affaires d'affaires en 2020 a été
significative on faisait à peu près 15 %
on alentours de 48 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2020 on en faisait
55 en 2019
donc c'est une baisse significative mais
effectivement il ya une opportunité
puisque il ya le développement des
véhicules électriques électrifié que ce
soit des hybrides ou des véhicules 100%
électriques
elle est
elle est vraiment en très forte
progression de veau au niveau des ventes
de nos clients et nous ça nous amène des
gros challenge d'adapter nos moyens
d'essais de repenser nos compétences
autour de ce véhicule électrifiée et on
emprunte de préparer aussi activement le
véhicule avec une combustion hydrogène
que ce soit la pile à combustible ou le
moteur thermique avec un carburant
hydrogène et pour accompagner ce
changement à l'état vous accompagner à
travers le fonds de modernisation de
l'automobile et de l'aéronautique alors
vous avez bénéficié de combien et à quoi
va servir cet investissement on a déposé
un projet en septembre 2020 au plein
coeur de la crise on a une réponse
positive de l'état de la bpi fin d'année
2020 donc on va recevoir une subvention
d'environ 900 mille euros qui va servir
à créer ou moderniser des bancs d'essai
autour de trois thématiques les essais
de compatibilité électromagnétique pour
les moteurs électriques des bancs de
test pour les batteries de cyclage
électrique et thermique et être capable
de proposer aussi des essais feu sur les
batteries pour valider le bon
fonctionnement des batteries même sous
des environnements très agressif comme
le feu et cette activité se déroule à
montigné bretonnier je crois qu'on va
aller le voir c'est ça exactement
l'un des manches se déroule à montigny
mentionné en plein cours de construction
et on va les bas
on
c'est un banc pour tester les moteurs
électriques qui participent à la
traction des véhicules qu'ils soient
électriques ou hybrides
donc c'est la tendance actuelle du
marché automobile
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire lentement
on va venir tester des moteurs
électriques et vérifier la compatibilité
électromagnétique de ses moteurs c'est à
dire c'est à dire on va vérifier que ses
moteurs en fonctionnement n'émettent pas
trop dont des électro magnétiques ou au
moins dans les normes qui sont définies
et qui ne sont pas perturbés par les
ondes électromagnétiques qui sont dans
la nature quand on passe sous une ligne
haute tension et c'est parce que ça peut
perturber leur fonctionnement c'est ça
peut perturber le fonctionnement donc il
ya des normes
c'est une première en france parce que
des banques comme ça il y en a c'est le
premier qui va être construit en france
donc qu'est ce qui va permettre de faire
il va permettre de tester sous charge
donc en rotation le moteur électrique
la spécificité de cette cage c'est
qu'elle elle filtre tous les ondes
électromagnétiques qui viennent de
l'extérieur et elle fait elle elle
empêche aussi les ondes
électromagnétiques qu'on va induire dans
cette cage vers l'extérieur
donc après la spécificité de cette de ce
banc c'est d'avoir un dispositif qui va
permettre d'entraîner le moteur
électrique du client
encore une fois je le rappelle qui va
être ici par une génératrice de charges
qui est ici donc la difficulté de
semences et un la vitesse de rotation
puisqu'on va tourner à plus de 22 mille
tours minute
donc il ya nécessité de très bien
alignées l'arbre de la machine
électrique avec le prototype clients
donc là on a déposé
réalisé un gros travail au sein de notre
bureau d'études avec des partenaires
merci sébastien photo merci directeur
des opérations autour de la mobilité au
sein du groupe elitech focus maintenant
sur le dispositif transition collective
qui fait l'objet d'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt par le gouvernement cette
mesure s'inscrit pleinement dans le plan
france relance objectif favoriser la
reconversion des salariés pour faciliter
la mobilité professionnelle dans des
secteurs en pleine croissance et dans un
même bassin d'emploi les détails dans ce
décryptage
[Musique]
d
et
[Musique]
oui
il a créé officiellement sa société en
octobre 2020 randy luc usa est un jeune
dirigeant d'entreprise développeur web
originaire des clayes-sous-bois et s'est
lancé dans l'entrepreneuriat après une
formation dans le numérique
son objectif accompagner les entreprises
à développer leurs compétences dans ce
domaine
c'est ma vie d'entrepreneur avec randy
luc usa sur des images de mélanie poker
[Musique]
je m'appelle ranger le coup ça je suis
fondateur et développeur chez le coussin
médias
[Musique]
du coup sa meilleure aujourd'hui c'est
une agence digitale
nous accompagnons toutes les entreprises
et même les particuliers aussi dans leur
parcours ni night on a plusieurs parcs
de nos services qu'on propose aux
entreprises et des plaques de création
d'identités visuelles jusqu'à la
conception distincts parlait tout de
même de l'application dans glee tout
dépend de la demande du client et nous
sommes là pour les accompagner dans
leurs projets leurs et des alti l'it as
visualiser
donc
j'ai un paquet stand jours ça a été
assiégée et après je voulais continuer
les études mais chercher notamment si
j'ai pas trop les alternances du coup je
me suis dirigé vers une formation
développeurs web chez hitchcock et après
ça je me suis vu que les alternances est
compliqué à avoir parce qu'il faut de
l'expérience on va se réappropriant
stoessel pour la formation de société
pour l'argent je vous se rapprocher de
clowns bloquent tout est parti des fonds
personnels
[Musique]
le but c'était pas vraiment de cet
épatant de temps ça de faire du chiffre
c'était plus pouvoir aider les autres à
faire du chiffre et plus on aide les
gens et musées nos clients cherchent à
se démarquer sur le numérique parce
qu'être le coc vide on sait que c'est
compliqué de le vendre comme ça
physiquement et il cherche plutôt
l'évasion numérique pour les aider
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]